welcome back to new rockstars this is
the big question the show that gives you
too much information on why living in
gotham city means that every trip to the
grocery store could be the moment that
you're killed by either batman or one of
his villains or literally anything else
don't go down an alley with your parents
uh just don't do it especially after
watching a play that is based in the
trauma that you just experienced not
sure why their parents would do that but
terrible parenting maybe they deserve to
die my name is mt and i'm here with
oscar producer brandon what's going on
brandon i can't believe you just said
the waynes deserve to die
that's a tape from empty
baby that's a hot take i like how
the story does keep changing like they
went to the opera then they went to a
play then they went to the movies like
what's going to be the next thing like
uh uh in in like 20 years the batman
like his parents took him to an nft
unveiling and then they got shotgun oh
mark so that
joe chill could steal the apple watch
that martha was wearing like that's
going to be the future version of batman
he's like i don't want to look at this
bat nft anymore dad can we go it's like
all right so thomas wayne is like these
nfcs are ruining the city
[Laughter]
what is our big question for today
brandon hit us well empty we've got a
fresh hot new sexy batman franchise on
our hands with that it means we get
another look at the worst city in
america gotham baby
you don't want to live here you know
this major metropolitan center of the dc
universe is consistently the worst place
you would ever want to be but what makes
it so bad why is it such a bad rat and
now that we have so many different
versions of gotham which one's the worst
huh like which which
gotham is the worst so that leads us to
this week's big question which movie
version of gotham would be the worst one
to live in the worst city
you are so right because like after like
watching the mandalorian in the book of
boba fett after all this time i'm just
like
i think i feel like tattoo is the worst
place to live no not after thinking
about it it's definitely gotham because
gotham
compared to gotham are you kidding me
are you kidding me
but yes we've had so many different
versions of gotham over the years and
one thing that they've all had in common
is a sense that gotham is not a super
friendly city to reside in situated in
the state of new jersey the city is
always depicted with a gothic
architecture and a healthy criminal
underworld so no wonder they need a
crusader flying around cleaning up crime
because these corrupt police officers
really aren't doing anything at all
times because gotham is just filled with
the worst of the worst
corrupt cops as we saw in the dark
knight trilogy yuck disgusting so let us
run through the different film versions
of gotham and see what each filmmaker
brought to the city on the coast to
bring the most danger possible to the
average everyday citizen so a quick
caveat we won't be covering the two
batman films from the 1940s or the
batman from from the 1966 film with adam
west those gotham seem like paradises
compared to the ones that we've seen in
later films so that's too easy yeah yeah
everyone would want to live in like the
adam west version of gotham it's oh
absolutely they're dancing everything is
really fun i'll be partying with adam
west all day oh yeah batman's throwing
like discos in that version it's a fun
time i would i would love to be
kidnapped by the joker in that universe
it just seems like really fun and goofy
i'll take you surfing i might die but
i'll i'll die having a good time but
we're also going to skip 2019's joker
film because that's a joker film and not
really a batman movie so we're not gonna
yeah we don't need that one let's get it
out of here i mean it's a great universe
and like that goth was pretty messed up
but like it's not really a batman film
so yeah but that's a sci-fi
so let us start with the latest
iteration of gotham it's the one we see
in the recently released the batman
movie from director matt reeves now
don't worry we're not going to spoil
anything about the film even though it
was phenomenal you should go see it matt
reeves really killed it so we'll see
that movie so we're not going to spoil
anything that wasn't already in the
trailers or any other marketing so yeah
chill out you're good so this version of
gotham makes it clear that there's an
upper and lower class primarily based on
wealth like those with means live in the
nicer raised portions of the city while
those without are forced to live down
below the elevated tracks in locations
like the narrows and the version of
gotham that we see in the film is very
much rife with corruption from the top
down organized crime has a stranglehold
on the city and no government
institution is safe and what's most
important is that this version of gotham
has a batman that is still very much new
to crime fighting and like he's still
working out his issues and just had
doesn't have the whole batman thing
figured out just yet and matt reeves
took some inspiration from the real city
chicago for his gotham and actually used
locations in the city for some of the
filming and he also told entertainment
weekly that films such as klute and
chinatown inspired the neo-noir style of
his film and this helps build on the
class tension brewing inside of gotham
you know the have and have-nots and the
good people are trying to change the
establishment from the inside but there
aren't enough good people to get the job
done so a batman flying around dealing
out his own brand of bat justice isn't
helping out either
that's not helpful at all yeah he's been
saying like all the promotional
materials for this so it's not a spoiler
but you know rapper pat instead of
saying like i've been batman for the
batman's been around for like a couple
years in this one and things have gotten
worse they're not getting better this
guy's not helping anything and the cops
are like who is this guy going around
beating people up breaking noses
breaking legs breaking wrists like we
don't have time for this someone
someone's got to get this guy out of
here he's busting my ass is what he's
doing he's creating more work for us
he's making me look jesus christ gotta
stop the batman but yeah like it's just
it's so weird like it must be so weird
from the police point of view because
it's just like this guy's just punching
people and things are just progressively
getting worse so like why are you even
doing it just stop just stop just we we
got it from beer yeah i've been on this
rant before you know i see jay jonah
jameson's perspective of spider-man i
also see it here with batman now granted
the the people in the government aren't
doing the things you're supposed to be
doing and there's a lot of corruption
and stuff but like how are you supposed
to get anything done you have this guy
operating outside the bounds of the law
doing all sorts of dangerous things
putting people in danger driving like a
maniac that car's not registered what's
going on out here maniac absolute maniac
but one telling thing that reeves told
entertainment weekly was gotham is never
not going to be corrupt because it's
like our world which is dark but kind of
true
what do you think about it yeah yeah
yeah i mean whoa as we kind of look at
the other gothams we'll see how they
different differentiate a little but
this is big from maurice because he's
basically saying like this problem's
never going to get fixed doesn't matter
if batman's here for two years if he's
here for 20 years there's always going
to be problems
and it's like it makes me think
someone's got to do something about
gotham when's the federal government
going to step in and do something
seriously gotham it's it's really
corrupt
it honestly feels like gotham is its own
country sometimes
right yeah they're like on their own i
mean that was really established in the
nolan verse when they're like uh just
they're fine they're fine the bridges
are closed it's fine they can't get out
uh we'll just leave it there yeah i
wouldn't i would definitely not want to
live in the matt reeves you know gotham
uh as you pointed out mt it's like a
neo-noir right it's it's going back to
those old like film noir tropes and one
thing about film noir is that like
there's no good anywhere everyone's dark
everyone's evil everyone's got a dark
side evil wins so like this gotham is
tough it's gonna it's a tough place to
live and people are getting murdered and
like brutal ways you know that clip from
the the funeral scene when when
everyone's inside the funeral but you
could hear like the screaming on the
outside like that's heavy right i don't
want to live in that gotham when that
when that kind of stuff's popping off no
thank you no thank you oh no i i just
don't like funerals in general yeah and
this is just the beginning of the the
decline of this gotham because we're
gonna get more it looks like in spin-off
series and a sequel to this film it's
looking like
can't wait can't wait i already can't
wait it's gonna be dope but yeah no i
think it just makes a lot of sense that
gotham is just always consistently going
to be corrupt because everyone just
loves batman and like as long as people
love batman gotham can't be fixed
because what is batman going to do that
he's just going to be a boring rich dude
yeah right we need a scene in a batman
movie where like the citizens turn to
the camera and they're like is this what
you want from us why are you doing this
from us
stop coming to batman movies
it's awful here please bro i would
really love if like a a marvel or dc
movie broke the fourth wall like that
and just like is the reason why we
suffer because of entertainment because
of people are you not entertained
well but especially with all the other
cities in like dc world right like uh
green lanterns from like coastal city
and it's like he's a even metropolis
it's like a dream you know what i mean
like
it's nice
there's crime sure but it's not like the
level you see in gotham someone has got
to help this poor city but now let's go
back in time a few years and talk about
the dceu version of gotham now we didn't
get as much of an in-depth look of that
version of bruce wayne's hometown but we
can still piece together a good idea of
just how bad it was from the hints that
we get from different films and that
picture is not exactly the most
prettiest picture because sure gotham in
the dcu might be a nice place to visit
during the day you know do some shopping
you know see some landmarks maybe catch
a football game definitely not in the
nolan universe don't do that but once
the sun sets and the night envelops the
city you better watch your back because
not only do the criminal gangs come out
to play but you have a grizzled old
pissed off affleck batman who beats the
living [ __ ] out of you the bat [ __ ] out
of your pants because he thinks that you
even looked at another criminal did you
see the warehouse scene
my oh my back still hurts what from
watching that scene some of those dudes
definitely died fatality you bring up a
good point empty cause like he's really
tough on the criminals you know and like
famously in batman vs superman they talk
about how he's like branding criminals
before he sends him to prison just to
torture him uh and just because he knows
they'll get their ass be even further in
prison because they got caught by the
batman and they have to wear his simple
for life on their skin for life yeah
like that is messed up yeah that's crazy
it's pretty hardcore prison life is not
easy it is not your life is alan prison
like there's this youtuber called jay
williams and he does i call jay williams
let's live life and he's basically a
dude that went to prison and he tells
his stories about being in prison and my
god your whole perspective of what
prison is changes because like it is a
violent scary place it's literally like
the times before society was even
invented it's like survival you're in
full survival mode all the time don't go
to prison don't do crime it's just the
worst thing don't do crime kids
god so like if you're if you're in
prison branded your life is even worse
bro yeah so like don't get branded i got
the prison too even worse the worst of
the worst criminals the riddler will
freaking tell you riddle before you take
your kneecaps
it'll be this who stole your ramen
noodles i did
what has one leg and no robin noodles
you
you i have two legs
[Laughter]
now this version of batman does have
some wins under his belt like he took
down the falconi and moroney crime
families and has bested some real
baddies from his rogues gallery like
harley quinn and the joker killer croc
and deadshot but he totally you know
lost a robin so there's that but one
thing that seems like a bright spot here
is that the police force appears to be
pretty cleaned up and i don't think you
need to worry about them as much as you
would you know the other batman universe
but it's clear that all of batman's hard
work hasn't amounted to a city that is
100 saved like this guy was literally on
the way to kill superman so like what's
wrong with him he had some like really
weird problems and like a really
strange attachment to the city that i
feel like is is very different from
other batman versions and as for the
look of this gotham they also used some
shots of chicago's skyline to represent
the city and this is something they
carried over from the nolan verse it's a
very modern looking city that still
reclaims some of its classic gothic
architecture and i think wayne
enterprises has done a good job of
maintaining the infrastructure of the
city and while organized crime does
still exist things seem to be trending
in the right direction here which is
great so what do you think about this
universe in general yeah i think you
know you pointed out we don't see too
much of the day ins day outs of this
gotham
but uh it seems like it's in the right
direction
uh
you know it's not as dingy looking as
we've seen i mean yeah the the like
warehouse at the docks looks bad but
that's every city
guys that's every warehouse in every
city at night but yeah it seems like
this gotham has been through the ringer
it's seen a lot but now they're kind of
just like coasting things have been
cleaned up there's been some
gentrification happening you know maybe
they cleaned up the narrows in this city
it's not as bad anymore there's a couple
starbucks there you can go walk uh you
know one of the old elevated train
platforms which turn into a city park
i'm sure the city's doing okay i still
think batman is a huge problem he's a
little unhinged but you know if they've
cleaned up the police department and
they're handling the like day-to-day
crime you can let batman go beat up a
few bad guys every now and then it's
okay uh but yeah this this gotham feels
like hey we've got our problems but look
at metropolis uh they've got some big
issues you know bruce had to drive into
the city to save his people like
come on this is true
we got you know you have powers and
you're letting the city get destroyed so
i think in comparison to metropolis like
this gotham doesn't seem so bad yeah you
can't walk around by yourself at night
but you know that's dangerous to do
anywhere this is true but i'm so
interested to see how this new
peacemaker show has added to the lore of
gotham because we know that like the mad
hatter existed at some point right there
a lot of the sillier villains definitely
existed in this gotham it had to be
dealt with it makes me wonder just like
how crazy and how kooky this universe
actually was in the past now that we're
we're getting like the actual og like
wild characters introduced into the
batman mythos so just like man like i
wonder if like how bad it used to be
like when he first started is what i'm
saying like it must have been like
really weird and he had just had a lot
of work to do
but you did you break up a good point
also mt with the fact that like this
batman the affleck batman he caught some
of his criminals and put him away for
good right you know he got dead shot
into the system he got killer croc into
the system you got calendar man he got
calendar man he got him all you know
he's he's flexing the bad guys so yeah
maybe maybe they were like you know you
know batman with some of these like
lesser villains like with mad hatter
don't kill him okay just
but for the press let us see you put
them in the little cute little bat
handcuffs uh
we'll do a purple walk with them but go
easy on them now if you go and you kill
a couple henchmen we're not gonna we
don't want to do the paperwork
you can kill a couple henchmen but with
the major ones let us let us have them
on tv let them have their day in court
let him let him get put
put into arkham asylum but now let's
venture into the gotham of the dark
knight trilogy because as we mentioned
before it's here that gotham started
taking a lot of inspiration from the
city of chicago but this is where nolan
filmed a lot of the exterior scenes in
the first two films while using
pittsburgh los angeles in new york city
for the scenes in the dark knight rises
it makes sense that he would jump around
a lot because nolan and his team wanted
elements from hong kong chicago new york
city and tokyo when expressing their
vision to the art department and this
creates a version of gotham that feels
real to audiences everywhere as they can
envision events in the trilogy happening
in their own major city which is pretty
dope and in the dark knight trilogy we
can see the rise of batman from the very
beginning ending with a city that no
longer needs him this is sort of in
contrast to the types of gothams that
reeves is currently building known's
films are centered around the idea of
hope that gotham can change which is
like very central to what the thomas
martha wayne was wanting to do with
their city like when they built the
whole train system and like wanted they
just wanted to build hope for for the
people and that's that that mission that
bruce wayne
adopts into is batman so it can be fixed
to the point where it no longer needs a
batman which is dope so if you're living
in this gotham you're dealing with the
same corruption that you'll find in any
version of gotham but the big bads here
are certainly putting the regular
civilians in harm's way a whole lot in
this universe because scarecrow's gas in
the water lines you know joker putting
bombs on the ferries bane locking all
the cops underground and having anarchy
in the streets uh not fun that football
field like i said before destroyed
you're not playing any games on there
for a while i'm giving you your city
back
[Laughter]
my favorite thing about that whole
moment is that like he waited for the
little boy to finish the anthem it was
like wow what a lovely voice i've got to
watch for this i used to dream to sing
the national anthem and it was stripped
away from me let the boy sing
sing again for me more
[Applause]
but yeah like i said i think this
version of gotham is probably the most
safest i feel and like the most hopeful
i in like the most
like i i feel like there is a a clear
distinction between all right like
things used to be really bad and like
then there's a period where thomas and
mother wayne helped things out and then
now we have this you know period of
prosperity or or better things are
happening now that you know the world
doesn't need a batman and like you know
people have learned the lessons of the
joker of like working together and like
you know
people have you know learned the
commentary of bane and these people and
so like people have learned the lessons
and so i was like we don't really need
batman we'll take it from here
we don't need you
i don't know how well that's going to go
hopefully
joseph gordon-levitt knows how to punch
real good fatality
we assuming he steps into the role as
like nightwing or something i mean
they're kind of on their own because
batman's was just like nah i'm gonna
leave i'm gonna pretend like i died
that's cool
yeah right it's like in about like a
decade batman swoops into the city
knocks it around a little bit lets some
big bad things happen and then it's like
you know what you guys are good i think
i fixed it well done
cleaned it up
hanging up the old kitchen
having lunch you just drop in and just
smack the lip pull back drop down
but yeah this this version of gotham it
goes through a lot in like a kind of
short period of time but it does get
cleaned up and gets to a good place and
batman decides he can move on you know
it's a very hopeful thing it's what we
want for gotham we want it to clean up
its act i imagine that the problems keep
happening because that's gotham for you
and yeah like you said joseph
gordon-levitt has to clean it all up now
because batman just decided to leave
that's cool i guess whatever but this
one would be tough because you're right
mt there's civilians are put in danger
and used as pawns a ton in this because
that's batman believes so much in gotham
especially in the nolan verse that
that's the best way to hurt him is to
show him like no this city isn't worth
your time the city shouldn't be saved
from like razal ghoul being like uh this
city is done we're finished with it
we're gonna get it out of here uh we run
the world and we've seen it all and this
is awful this is disgusting
this is awful in every way if i could
kill it i would all the way up to you
know to bain being like look at these
people tear each other apart i put all
the cops underground and look at them
they can't handle themselves now i think
if you're living in this city you got to
be like guys i can't believe you all
went underground like
some of you should have stayed behind
what were you thinking like this was a
horrible idea so maybe get gordon out of
there he's maybe a little too old to be
commissioner get a little more tactical
guy in there to handle these bad guys
but in the end this gotham is in a
pretty good place it's it's not a bad
place to live i think just don't go to
any sporting events and you'll be safe
just don't do it it's fine and like i
feel like a huge threat to this gotham
in this universe was the league of
shadows and now that you know reject
ghoul and bain are gone and the joker is
taken care of and you know
hypothetically in his own prison now
that heath ledger is no longer with us i
just feel like this universe this batman
universe can you can realistically say
alright i don't think any major
craziness is going to happen here now
that like these major like forces are
now
off to the side and taken care of now
you know obviously your joker can escape
but he's done multiple times but like i
feel like in this more grounded universe
you could say that all right we got the
joker and he never came back because
we're we're really good at like keeping
you or that [ __ ] up we got him ladies
and
gentlemen we got him
because that's like the main problem you
know in comic books in general right
that's the most
that's where you have to suspend your
disbelief the most is that like these
villains don't usually die
and they don't stay in prison you can't
you know we need them for you want to
read about them you don't want the story
to be over you want more fun more action
more more suspenseful tales but in
reality it would be insane to think that
like why is these guys keep getting out
of prison why are you why are we even
bother locking them up in prison kill
these guys right now look at me
you see how easy it is you see how easy
it is to slip right down that path i
hate when people are always like if we
if we kill the joker we're not as good
as he bro i'm gonna keep it real with
you man i think this guy's a word real
he's earned a killing i think you know
what i mean
if the joker was real and did as much
terrible things as he's done in the
comics and i had the opportunity to kill
the joker i would probably do it i would
feel guilty about killing a man for a
very long time but my god he has killed
so many people that like
what
why wouldn't you do it like he's the
only person in like
ever that i would ever kill because are
you sure about that sorry maybe i should
prevent it well this is empty would kill
a man i mean
you know in the
tim burton universe batman gets to kill
the joker uh and it does not bring him
solace
it's something he passes on to robin the
concept that like killing the people the
person who killed your parents does not
bring you resolution and all it does is
make a hole for you to fill with bodies
dropping bodies left and right let the
bodies hit the floor that's the danger
of like you gotta be better than that
you know you gotta strive to be better
than that but in the nolan verse you
know batman very smartly makes himself
the villain right he is the dark knight
he allows himself to be the bad guy so
that also kind of makes sense while at
the end he's like i gotta go because
everyone thinks i
you know hurt harvey dent and stuff so i
i gotta get out of here
[Music]
why are you running and harvey dent in
the nolan universe is a great example of
the frustration and the stress of trying
to do the right thing in this horribly
corrupt city and what it leads you to uh
and you start realizing that hey maybe
these criminals are right maybe it's the
only way to get things done is to have a
little violence and a little pain and a
little killing but batman showed us
that's not the way that's not the way
you just got off you know i think you
stopped me from becoming harvey dent
just now i could have just become i got
to pull you back from the end stops me
from
you stop me from embracing my dark side
i guess i would spare the joker now
that's good that's good lesson of the
day kids uh don't don't let the rage
consume your soul empty i'm gonna take
over for this last one because this is
my batman this is my god okay it's
finally time to discuss the most
beautiful gotham that is the gotham that
was created by tim burton and further
evolved by joel schumacher yes the og
batman well not the og i mean og to a
lot of us the batman released in 1989
and directed by tim burton helped revive
the superhero film genre which i've been
declining since its heyday of like the
richard donner superman films which were
very popular but then people were kind
of getting tired of them but unlike the
shiny metropolis represented in those
movies burton wanted to show a gotham
that was a dark and gothic city his
production designer anton first
described the look of gotham as quote if
hell erupted through the pavement and
kept on going i mean that is a dark city
folks that is crazy yeah um
this is like definitely the most comic
book version of gotham we would ever see
um they've never even really gotten
close to coming back to this it's not
super realistic but it's very distinct
in its style and if you've seen the
animated batman series there's
definitely a lot of kind of crossover
there in that kind of gothic
styling the first two films in this
franchise of four kind of definitely
represent that they're much darker much
more gothic uh the corruption in gotham
has led to businesses not contributing
to the city it's causing the tax base to
crumble and the city's infrastructure
along with it so this is like a broken
down gotham that has like nothing going
for it and it's just a mess and then
joel schumacher takes over for the final
two films in the franchise and the city
gets a little more neon uh while still
keeping its architectural style there's
all these roving thematic gangs that
continue to get like bigger and bigger
so at least it's easy to tell who a bad
guy is because they're dressed in like
matching uniforms with like bright neon
colors which is fun that's the batman
universe yeah yeah it's fun but it's
like super unsettling especially just
like walking along and you're like oh
here comes much but ice skating bad guys
we got to worry i'll worry about now
oh it's the freaking royal flush gang uh
here they come all right
i will also say in like the the burton
schumacher verse right uh in this
version of gotham the police force is
not as corrupt as they'll be represented
in later films uh but they're still
pretty useless like the commissioner
gordon in these movies is just like he
lets batman do his thing but pretty much
relies on him to fix like any problem
he's just constantly turning
like uh i mean i don't i don't know what
to do here
bank robbery pick up the phone
i think it's like the batman movies you
know as we go along in time they get
they rely more on like really showing
the corruption like the police force
there's certainly still corruption here
but like it's not like it is now there
you know nolan really wanted to bring
that realism to superhero films
especially batman but it is fun to go
back and look at what if we just really
took it right from the pages of the
comic book and made it look like that as
much as possible so if you're a citizen
in like the burton verse you're gonna
face some pretty big and wacky dangers
okay uh you know you got the joker
spraying his smiling gas during a parade
where he's tossing out cats terrifying
uh terrifying i've always been terrified
of like being exposed to joker talks and
like that no thank you yeah yeah i mean
that was like pretty dark but it is it
comes with like a funny twist that
you're smiling i guess i i don't know
it's true uh it is a cure for
of the smiling the non-smiling part of
depression uh you'll still be depressed
but smiling but smiling people won't ask
you about it you're gonna have to worry
about like the penguin you know stealing
your children uh in the night and also
having militarized the penguins at the
zoo that's pretty scary uh a penguin
with a misalignment scary pretty
frightening especially if you have a
penguin phobia yeah yeah you're gonna
have to worry about the riddler like
sucking away your brain waves via free
3d entertainment does anybody else feel
like a fried egg and most importantly
you don't have to worry about mr freeze
you know like locking you away in ice
just as you're walking down the street
just get freeze well
freeze so these are like big
big wacky dangers big goofy dangers uh
that you're gonna have to deal with but
the city looks beautiful i mean what a
fun
city to live in and like i said like
you're gonna know if you're you're
facing a bad guy like don't go down an
alleyway that's got all this neon
uh painting on it because it's probably
full of a neon gang okay you're in the
neon gang district get out of there and
yeah this city still definitely has its
upper class and it's lowered class but
it still seems like a fun city to live
in you just got to deal with all this
batman nonsense seems pretty dangerous
to me man i could not go to sleep
knowing that penguin and his penguin
army were out there it could potentially
rob me and my
yeah
stuff
didn't do it it is a danger you're gonna
face empty but like you're gonna know
who the bad guys are they're gonna stand
out that's what's helpful you know
what's what's creepy and like you know
the the dark knight right is when the
joker is disguised as a police officer
and he looks like a police officer here
it would be you know mr freeze with his
big bulky outfit and his blue face
putting on a cop outfit and you'd be
like that's mr freeze dressed as a cop
i'm not i'm not worried about that
imagine he tried it it was just like no
one knows it's me no it's not it's me
everything is fine this is a normal
parade you play you play bad cop i'll
play gold cop and you're like ah jesus
this guy's mr freeze
and that's the other thing you're going
to tell us about jokes you're going to
face some pretty dangerous puns if
you're living in like this oh yeah
pretty awesome pretty bad puns the other
cool thing is in this version of gotham
city is you're going to see batman like
really flex on like his car his his bat
jet his bat boat i mean the first batman
movie we get this awesome batmobile and
we get to see his bat jump
so good yo the batmobile from that movie
is literally so iconic i remember having
an action figure of it as a kid it was
literally my favorite toy and i lost it
i still think about it to this day i'm
very upset that i lost it it was only
like a mcdonald's one so it's really
hard to think about it now because
superhero movies are so ubiquitous
[Applause]
as part of our metaculture but when this
movie came out it rocked people's worlds
they were ready for it bro
and they were like this was these are
what comic book movies could be and yeah
it goes back you go back now and it
feels a little goofy and it's a little
wild but these were important these were
made by filmmakers who
watched the old batman show and which
was campy and silly and read the old
batman comics which were campy and silly
and they were trying to bring a little
darkness to them and make them feel a
little more gritty but it was still like
what if i could have my comic book i
grew up with up on the big screen and
it's really impressive what they did
with it and what a fun city to live in
what a stylized city to live in like
it's cool that gotham now looks like
other major cities but like what fun to
see a gotham that was very different and
very stylized it's kind of crazy to
think how before
this movie
yeah we only really had those like silly
comics and the silly tv shows to really
um base this universe off of but they
still did a great job at melding the the
silliness with the realism to give us a
a universe that was just like all right
the kids can enjoy it and the adults can
enjoy it like this is like the perfect
film for every age range even though it
is it gets kind of adults
it gets silly batman and robin is
a really rough way to end in this little
franchise yeah that's not great but you
know i i say check them out if you've
never seen them they're great or if you
like bad nipples it'll be a real nice
juxtaposition between watching matt
reeves batman and going back and
watching like the burton and schumacher
batman for sure
you'll appreciate how time has gone on
so brandon after all this discussion
which gotham city do you think would be
the most dangerous to live in uh geez mt
i think gonna have to go with you know
the matt reeves gotham city because he's
pretty much saying that like it ain't
gonna get any better and it's always
gonna be worse and that one like
batman's not fixing anything but i kind
of tie it with like uh you know like the
burton verse because while i don't think
i'm gonna get killed in the burn verse i
think at some point i'm either gonna get
you know wacky frozen and iced or i'm
gonna get my brain drained or something
like something's bad's gonna happen to
me i'm not gonna die but something goofy
as hell was gonna happen to me i'll put
it as a tie in between the matt reeves
universe cause i'm gonna die in the
burton universe because i'm gonna get
turned into like a balloon animal or
something like that that's a really good
one that's a really good pick
well those are two really good picks
because i tied it i cheated but
you cheated but i'm gonna say
definitively that it's the dcu batman oh
okay because i just think that
especially with peacemaker just adding
all this new lore to the dceu now that
we have batman to the picture like if i
lived in a universe where batmite was
just like changing things kite man just
running around just being wild and like
all these like people in gotham that we
haven't seen yet i just feel like
there's a rich history of gotham like
you said man of steel even though like
that's metropolis i just feel like
there's a lot more
things are getting a lot more crazier in
the dcu that i'm just like i wouldn't
feel comfortable living there personally
i don't know i would say dce yeah that's
a great point empty because yeah peace
breakers kind of established that like
anything that's existed in the comics
has probably shown up in the dc eu so
yeah all bets are on the table every
villain exists in gotham now and that's
a real problem that's a very dangerous
city you're right and like i'd probably
be a butterfly honestly because
half of the
population was a butterfly so like i
would be it's totally my brain would be
right stuff and just juice but hey head
on over to new rockstarsmerch.com to
check out our latest obsession shirt
inspired by the batman and this is our
limited edition shirt so once it's gone
it's gone for good it's never coming
back the riddler stole it batman put it
back into the bat cave we we tipped over
the penny in the back game
we can no longer lift up the penny i'm
so sorry um and they have so
and they also have some other batman
inspired t-shirts along with multiple
sock designs and even a riddler tie for
formal events so find all this cool
merch and lots more over at
newrockstarsmerge.com and before we dive
into our bite size questions next some
words from the people that help us bring
big question to you people like mint
mobile receiving more and spending less
is one of your top goals for 2022 stop
paying insane amounts of money every
month for wireless why would you do that
love yourself save by switching to mint
mobile as the first company to sell
premium wireless service online only
mint mobile lets you maximize your
savings with plans starting at just 15
bucks a month and we've got folks on the
new rockstar staff who have switched to
mint mobile and love it they kept their
phones and their number and they pay way
less and by going online only and
eliminating the traditional cost of
retail mint mobile passes significant
savings on to you and all plans come
with unlimited talk and text plus high
speed data delivered on the nation's
largest 5g network with mint mobile
choose the amount of monthly data that's
right for you and stop paying for data
that you just never use switch to mint
mobile and get premium wireless service
starting at just 15 bucks a month to get
your new wireless plan for just 15 bucks
a month and get the plan shipped right
to your door for free go to
mintmobile.com bigq that's
mintmobile.com
big q cut your wireless bill to 15 bucks
a month at mintmobile.com
b-i-g-q big cube there's a new expansion
out for the critically acclaimed mmo rpg
guild wars 2 called end of dragons
someone's got to put a stop to these
dragons
join the welcoming and supportive guild
wars 2 community of more than 16 million
commanders by downloading the game from
the link in this video's description the
expansion has a bunch of new features
for fans of the game and even more ways
to enjoy it for new players in guild
wars 2 you unlock and train your mount
to leap across canyons bound up high
cliffs and skim over water and quicksand
now you can take a ride with your
friends on the all new multiplayer siege
turtle yep you and your friend can ride
around on a boat
finally finally a turtle built for war
uh explore the four reimagined maps
aboard your personal skiff drop anchor
to fish over 200 unique species you can
even compete in fishing events you
thought you could only do that in the
real world well now you can do it in
guild wars 2. one of the coolest things
about guild wars 2 is that you're always
rewarded for helping other players guild
wars 2 was designed to respect your time
and wallet with horizontal progression
and no subscription fee ever
ever
check in on 500 years there won't be a
subscription fee
click the link for click the link in
this video's description to download
guild wars 2 end of dragons today
get your siege turtle right now get on
your siege turtle [ __ ] we're going to
war
we'll get there eventually
and hey if you have a few seconds to
help the show and our channel click the
link in the video description to take a
quick survey it will help us choose
sponsors relevant to our fans so check
out the link in the description to give
us some feedback so you can see more
stuff that is relevant to you like stuff
that you like yeah i love a good service
so you give me a survey any day of the
week i'm here everyone loves to take a
survey especially when they're on a
receipt but now it is time for our bite
size questions brenda are you ready i am
ready sir cause i got a big one for you
i don't know if you're ready supposed to
be bite-sized don't give me the big one
i'm sorry i'm gonna give you the biggest
bite-sized
question i can get you all right because
i need you to have the nutrients in your
body how is the power granted to a jedi
through the force different from the
power granted to a sith through the
force and this is from crispy chrissy on
discord crispy chrissy thank you for
remaining crispy all this time yes yes
thank you
well in the star wars universe both jedi
and the sith are adept at using the
force for the jedi
yeah i would hope they're good at it i
mean guys we're trusting you guys to be
the bosses of this okay here we go for
the jedi this often means drawing on a
skill set that embraces the light side
of the force and for the sith they lean
on the dark side but are these sources
of power different
not necessarily because once you go
black you don't go back that's the
difference that's what they say what
darth vader said
um
do it
do it i'll use a clumsy analogy here but
both sith and jedi are drawing their
force water from the same force well
it's just the jedis choose to drink the
water and the sith opt for spitting that
water into your eye
so it's all about how you use the water
is the big difference the concept of the
light and dark side of the force was
created by the force wielders themselves
you see if you believe what most people
believe the force is one i'm going to
force the forces with me it's not two
parts it's just one force a force the
force so if you choose to harm your
enemy or overcome some situation through
like selfish shenanigans well my friend
you're tapping into the dark side
however if you're using defensive
abilities healing or creating some sort
of diversion so you and your friends can
get away you might be a jedi folks to
further support the idea that there is
but one force a jedi can slip in some
dark side abilities now and then and a
sith can utilize some light side powers
if they so choose
the force is there for everyone if you
have a high enough midichlorian count
but just make sure you use it as you see
fit folks
[Music]
there's not like different sides of the
force it's all one force it's just like
how you use it and often like those dark
side abilities
of the force they they're more taxing on
your body that's why often you see
sith members who look pained uh it's
because the the powers that they're
they're drawing on like they they really
they draw your life force they they make
you look more evil and dark right
but yeah it's all the same force
um it's just also i think the sith
they're a little cooler right the jedi
they do some cool stuff i mean yeah the
sith are a lot cooler i mean the jedi
are just a bunch of like church people
let's be real just a bunch of pastors
with swords and the sith are just like
hey use your feelings man what you want
to go do crying let's do crime yeah
we're gonna go have sex and shoot
lightning out of our hands
pre-marital i wouldn't i wouldn't even
dream of it that's the path to the dog
side now brad and i got another
bite-sized question for you because
these are bite-sized so they're easily
edible you're ready for another one yes
i'm ready what are some of batman's
weirdest gadgets this is from singing
beef stew on twitter thank you cnb stew
never stop singing beef stew never stop
singing that stew uh well the batman
comics have certainly provided some
strange gadget at batman's disposal over
the years also the adam west tv show
often had some really weird things going
on absolutely
yeah here here are some of the weirder
ones that we found you've probably seen
this meme there's that classic shark
repellent from the adam west tv series
you know why does batman have shark
repellent well i guess in case a shark
tries to buy batman but he's got it duh
there was like a a spin-off comic that
showed that batman has a spray that
could repel female villains only female
villains a weird thing to spend your
time well that's uh my my uh sweat
that's uh that's the spray that helps
her repel females they somehow bottled
it's my juices
from high school and put it into batman
exactly i don't know the essence of
wetness in some of the early batman
comics uh he said that both he and robin
always keep at least one crayon in their
utility belt uh it came in handy when
they needed to make a poster uh so i
guess i always got a
crayon a weed no this is a crayon
what germans that is the weirdest thing
one crayon you'll never know what color
i said at least one because he says in
the strip like in the panel something
like at least we always have this crayon
on our utility belt it's like only one
why not a pencil or a pen or marker like
crayon i'd like to think that he does
like checks on robin he's like alright
robin you have everything utility about
wait a minute where's your crayon
i told you never leave your house
without your crayon
rachel
what is this rosary we only use crayola
slap i had to put you back in that
orphanage where i found you there was a
comic where batman was carrying napalm
nepal wow napon and a crayon
it's highly volatile it spreads it's
it's it's it's a war crime to use it no
napalm batman no dayton come on dude
hey man if poison ivy gets a little bit
too out of control you need that nape
home that's that's a scorched earth
approach right there batman also likes
to keep a lollipop on his utility belt
to help calm down the kids this one i
actually like because he's going to run
into some traumatized children you know
they've said that like a lot of police
officers will keep like a teddy bear in
the trunk of their car in case they're
ever dealing with a situation where
there's like a little kid and they make
them feel a little better i like that
batman keeps a lollipop i like to wonder
too that like sometimes he's like out
there and he's like man
i gotta i need a snack so i got this
lollipop but i don't run into any kids
later
he shows up to an alleyway with a kid
right down here like she's just like
it's a lollipop in his mouth he's like
you just hands to the kid you want it
gives the kid like a bit of my mouth but
they immediately bite into it and get
the gum he's like no you have to suck on
it you can't fight into it it's cheating
and finally while he didn't do it in
later years during the golden age of
comics batman was often strapped he was
carrying around a gun this deranged
lunatic was carrying a gun
folks are you saying that
dceu batman is actually comics accurate
i mean it kind of is cause like yeah if
you go back
you know later batman swore away guns
but early batman he was like give me a
gun i'm going out there he was like i
got a canadian act dressed as a clown
give me a gun
um i don't know if you guys noticed but
these people are the sons of mothers i
have to kill them give me a gun
i have to kill these bad guys or
gotham's never going to get better thank
you for these amazing answers to these
questions brandon you are a smart man
and we are lucky to have you with your
insights because what i had to know um
about that lollipop that he gives to
children because the children have to be
calmed because the trauma will just
settle in too hard yeah it just makes
more villains if you don't calm down
these traumatized children you're gonna
have more villains on your head exactly
exactly
i would love if they like actually made
that can it's like i just don't want to
make villains ma'am
but now it's time for the box of scraps
brandon who bought some craps
bills is in a cave with a box of
scratches but his
this is kind of you know
kind of a scary topic because we're
going to talk about the scariest
situation that you've ever found
yourself in well in a major city
what do you what do you think that is
for you uh for me when i was a young lad
uh we were visiting nashville tennessee
ever heard of it uh and
there you know we were it was like a
normal day it was pretty nice that was
in the summer but then this like kind of
storm rolled in and
i'm not even joking empty uh a tornado
like went through like downtown
nashville uh and usually you know i grew
up in the south i'm used to tornadoes
you're you know you see him out in the
field somewhere
or you know it's going through like the
farmlands seeing like a tornado in like
a major city with like big buildings and
stuff all this debris flying around and
crazy stuff like that that's frightening
and that's really scary because you're
like i'm gonna get sucked out of this
building uh and get slammed into another
building like uh
very very scary to be in a city when
like a tornado hits
bro no like whenever i see footage of
like tornado chasers and like storm
chasers just going to tornadoes i'm like
bro are you insane like are you lit
because that is literally like
a godlike event
destroying [ __ ] like that is beyond
anything that i can even fathom because
it's so huge and destructive i would
never want to see a tornado in my life
um i could never go to sleep again so i
won't even i wouldn't i wouldn't even do
the tornado the twister experience at
universal studios don't even put me in
that now it's too realistic
too real
real too traumatizing
um i think the scariest situation that i
can remember
um this is probably not the scariest
that i've ever been in but like
it's my first memory like when my brain
turned on because uh my first memory was
i remember visiting um a city in haiti
um and i was in the back of a motorcycle
i don't know why my mom decided to put
me in the back of a motorcycle behind my
mom but it was my it was the guy my mom
and then me at the back of the
motorcycle hanging on to my mom you were
holding my brain was like oh my god
like i'm like three four years old
and i'm alive and my brain turned on and
that was the first memory i ever
remember
ever so that's the scariest moment and
hence why i have anxiety as an adult
so if you so when you become a big
villain like your thing is going to be
destroying motorcycles right you're
going to be oh yes we have to burn all
the motorcycles
me and uh me and ghostwriter have a beef
my arch nemesis
um i just destroy motorcycles and he
avenged the ghosts or the motorcycles
you're like mr rider i have no qualms
with whatever you're doing but i gotta
destroy that motorcycle i'm so sorry
yeah i'm sorry
harley davidson is a dead man yeah did
you get yourself like a nice sedan to
drive around and you could still whip
your chain outside the windows sedan
yeah i gotta destroy your motorcycle
yeah robbie reyes he has a nice car
maybe carpool with him while you guys
are doing your thing but the motorcycle
gotta go um
that's that's my origin story for sure
but that is it for this episode of big
question i wanna give a huge thank you
to brandon for joining me on this
episode follow him at grindenberric on
twitter because he is the best and he
tweets some great stuff so follow him
there follow me at mastertainment on
twitter to see me tweet some weird stuff
but follow new rockstars here on youtube
and on all other social media platforms
make sure to hit that notification bell
so you can get notifications every time
we upload a video and hey if you want to
continue the new rockstars conversation
join our new rockstars discord server
which is now open to the public but if
you are 18 years old or older only so
click on the new rockstars discord link
in the description box to join us today
but again thank you guys for joining us
this video we love you guys so so much
we appreciate you spending time with us
and we'll see you guys next time goodbye
yeah bye
[Music]
you